e hoje eu tenho medo Este é o sono vocês
vão ouvir para sempre no vosso ouvido se
não deixar um like é macumba do Dark
frame Olá tudo isso pessoal aqui quem
fala andar que sejam muito bem vindos a
mais um vídeo eu hoje trago-vos aqui
depois pessoal nós temos aqui uma caixa
que eu já não abre há muito tempo agora
que o quarentena tá muito difícil chegar
as coisas meu demora muito tempo mês
enfim pessoal ela tem aqui alguns
produtos da Wish e o que eu tenho aqui
pessoal é bem específico eu comprei esse
nove coisas mais pequenas que eu
consegui encontrar não isso vou deixar a
caixa aqui do lado mas tem aqui muita
coisa dentro porque é que será que vem
aqui dentro o resto já estava aberto
porque eu tive que ver o que tinha aqui
né Mas pela caixinha certamente é uma
coisa pequena Vamos lá ver o que é que
tem aqui dentro Okay o que é isto eu
comprei um mínimo e crombies olha aí
Ah eu não acredito que eu fui gastar
dinheiro neste micro-ondas quem é o
micro-ondas em miniatura deve ser usado
para as casinhas de bonecas né eu não
vejo ser utilizado em mais lado nenhum
olha entenda uma portinha abre assim ele
é feito de madeira meu até que os
números todos mesmo tipo micro-ondas a
sério que eu estou a ver aqui eu paguei
dois euros e Meio Dois eram 60 por esta
miniatura Será que Compensou o preço
e eu acho que não eu acho que não Eu
Dúvido vocês encontrei no microondas com
este também só cabe na palma da mão mas
pelo menos está bem feito então eu
gostei fora lá próximo que é que nós
temos aqui
o que é isto
é bem como plástico é Dourado eu não
acredito este tá incrível este eu vou
usar meu se funcionar Bora lá ver se
funciona juntos pessoal bora
o que pode não Ok sem o cereja melancia
e o bar Ok vamos tentar outra vez sem
alguma coisa bo413 melancias calma calma
calma
as duas mãos isso outra vez
e oque eu disse aqui em cima hoje é que
pode eu 777 pois tem estas combinações
aqui todas também ok então objetiva
pegar o set
Olá boa Bora lá pessoal próximo
embalagem o já estou a ver que uns
Palitos fiz ok Espero que venha com
livro de instruções exatamente só não é
besta é uma besta em miniatura com vocês
sabem uma vez que é uma arma tipo assim
também real é uma coisa deixe também e
esta é em miniatura Ela diz para Palitos
e como podem ver alguém desmontado Então
vamos montar a
E aí
em qualquer pessoa eu acho que tá
sobraram aqui algumas peças e que estas
duas aqui eu quero ver a potência diz eu
acho que não puxar este primeiro
e assim exato ok pessoal está montado
Olha aí agora vai gostar pessoal a curta
distância agora 321 potência até porque
isto é uma corda Isto é um arame de aço
que esta miniatura é muito boa eu vou
testar outra vez o
a gestão daqueles produtos que eles
dizem que é gratuito que vocês podem
comentar a vontade que não vão pagar mas
vocês pagam sempre esportes então
Tecnicamente vocês estão a pagar o
produto no esporte então este que estou
três horas Ok mas qualquer forma vale os
três horas Ok eu gostei muito esta acho
que tá a minha segunda favorita ok que é
que nós temos aqui Como podem ver isto é
mesmo uma miniatura mas eu não sei do
quê Ah já sei o que é já me lembro de
ter comprado isto Este é um bloco de
notas mais pequeno do mundo é desse
tamanho só eu nem sei se estão bem um
bloco de notas Isto é daquelas coisas
que os médicos usam para colocar na cama
dos pacientes sabem mas é tão pequeno
que eu nem consigo de Carol mas tem que
ir várias folhas
e dá realmente para escrever Aff mas
como podem ver é muito pequeno estava na
ponta do meu dedo que este pessoal é o
bloco de notas mais pequeno do mundo
próximo produtos Ok Esse é pesado ou já
me lembro de ter comprado isso ok ok ok
nós estamos aqui dentro pessoal como
podem ver nós temos aqui comida nós
temos aqui um e no último McDonald's Ok
tem aqui coca-cola as batatas fritas ou
hambúrguer um cachorro quente e tu é uma
antes talvez eu tenho que ver essa
coca-cola aí que louco meu coca-cola
está em perigo Se bem que estão é bem
mais aqueles mini Cola muito estranho OK
mas Tecnicamente é uma coca-cola temos
aqui o que o hamburguer hamburguer está
incrível veja o detalhe pessoal não sei
se vão conseguir ver aí mas vejam os
detalhes visto que este é o hambúrguer
mais podre de sempre só tenho carne
alface ou a dor muito seco isto tinha de
ter queijo pelo menos estamos aqui com o
cachorro
oi oi mais uma couve salsicha então é
amarelo bom radioativo cair pois aqui as
batatas fritas do McDonald's e sei as
batatas estarem completamente Ok disto
eu gostei isso aqui tá louco e temos
aqui uma sandes ou seja um pão um pão
com ovo que é que vai comer pouco Olha
isso ninguém vai comer um pão com como
eu falei quanto por isso por acaso notas
que eu quero construir uma casinha de
bonecas Porque eu só estou comprar
coisas de né mini-bloco de notas do mini
micro-ondas o as minhas comidas para o
micro-ondas ok esta embalagem é muito
grande esta é muito grande para ser uma
miniatura O que é que vem aqui dentro Ok
tem uma caixa
é mais nada aqui dentro só Plast
a hocks parece um suporte Será que tem
alguma coisa a ver com cozinha e ou já
sei o que é que já sei o que é que eu
lembro eu lembro foi comprado isso aqui
dentro pessoal nós vamos encontrar
talvez uma guitarra Olha ainda não
miniatura meu tá muito bom esta tá muito
boa
e em madeira e tudo meu os detalhes diz
que estão incríveis as cordinhas encobre
não não misturar o está muito bom sério
eu não sei se vai focar pessoal mas vejo
o detalhe das cordas meu está perfeito
está perfeito e Agora resta saber se ela
realmente toca meu se tocar
G1
ai que bosta né
o OK Não funciona e beijão detalhe aqui
da Caixa Olha tem um furo aqui dentro
aqui por fora é como se fosse uma pele
falsa ou pele sintética Ok e tem que o
Face funciona perfeitamente Mas vamos
aguardar lá meu incrível e aqui está
Pessoal esse é o famoso estão vocês
viram o meu também nele vamos ver vem
com qualidade ou não mas eu acho que
aqui dentro vem o nosso iPhone 12 para o
Max em miniatura de which não é tão
pequeno que nem dá para ver dentro do
plástico que é que tem alguma coisa aqui
dentro ó
e foi um poste e dentro de um plástico
meu Deus é muito tempo Olha aí eu sou
dizer porque ontem o menu muito meu Deus
tem o menu ok ok está incrível está
difícil a minha muito grande aqui tem o
menu do iPhone perfeito como podem ver é
o novo iPhone 12 promax
Ou pelo menos homem não pense que é do
iPhone Ok como podem ver Pessoal esse é
o menu até tem wallpaper do novo iPhone
então certamente que é o 12 Olha aí não
sei se vai dar para ver mas ó esse ela
não vai forte eu paguei três Euros por
isto meu mas pelo menos adiantado ó
o que eu mais gostei mesmo assim
continua a ser a nossa foto mas sim não
está incrível ok que é que nós temos
aqui é uma coisa bem pequena e bem
pesada um ok pessoal que é que nós temos
aqui nós temos aqui uma mini faca Olha
aí é bem pesada Ok vamos ver se eu
consigo abrir Olha aí
e aqui tá pessoal é uma mini faca eu não
sei se ela corta eu não sei se ela tem
lâmina né Mas a partir da sim a parte
dela funciona Ok eu vou deixar aqui aí a
corta incrível e corta muito bem até
e o
e ela corta tanto o papel como o
plástico tem lá por dentro ok pessoal
mas também faca funciona Isto é
Tecnicamente um porta-chaves ele veio
aqui com o acessório com uma argola Olha
como podem ver bem que com esta argola
para vocês colocarem aqui na ponta e
podem usar como acessar pode dar jeito
Um dia sei lá teu ouvido que vocês
também encontrei uma faquinha destas
pessoa com este tamanho do vídeo e esta
vaquinha também é um dos produtos
gratuitos mas já sabem os fortes ficaram
por três euros e agora pessoal por fim o
último embalagem o que é que será que
vem aqui meu o que é que será que falta
de coisas mais pequenas do Instagram
pode é um passo é um passou acho que é
um prazer o é mesmo padrão Eu sabia que
o que é que vem aqui dentro Eu acho que
é uma arma de free Fire não sei porque
agora só resta saber que armem esta um é
uma metralhadora Ok mas bora lá montar
E aí
o irmão pessoal depois de alguns minutos
aqui está a nossa arma meu tá muito
linda até tenho que ir balas de fora
olha aí é aquela típica metralhadora sem
balas também não gostei assim tanto
demorou muito à montar qualquer das
maneiras pessoal é uma boa miniatura
devido poças arranjar esta arma tão
pequena e chegamos ao fim pessoal
comentem aí embaixo qual é que foi a
vossa favorita para mim sem dúvida foi
aqui as slot Machine meu Olha aí pessoal
Espero que tenham gostado aqui do vídeo
já está bem comente aí embaixo Qual é
que mais gostaram partilhem com os
vossos amigos e se quiserem mais vídeos
destes de Whisky comentem também e não
se esqueçam pessoal de passar pelo Canal
de jogos do Dark Frame 2 conhecer o
bairro onde postar vídeos de free Fire
de jogos de terror five Nights at
freddy's Inclusive estou a fazer algumas
leves agora também portanto se não
queres perder uma live passa lá é isso
Pessoal espero que tenham gostado aqui
do vídeo eu fiquei bem até a próxima
[Música]
E aí